نعود الان للتذكير بخبر زياره الرئيس
الروسي لشبه جزيره القرم حيث اكدت وسائل
اعلام الروسيه ان الرئيس الروسي قام
بزياره كما قلنا الى القرن التاسعه لضمها
لروسيا
هذا وقال مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
ان القرم ارض اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان بلاده
ستستعيدها بمساعده الدعم الدولي ياتي هذا
في ذكرى ضم روسيا لشبه الجزيره عام 2014
تاريخيا كانت شبه جزيره القرم في صلب
نزاعات وصراعات اقليميه منذ القدم
باهميتها الاستراتيجيه تقع شبه جزيره
القرم جنوب اوكرانيا بين البحر الاسود
وبحر ازوف ويفصلها عن روسيا مضيق كرش لها
مدخل نحو مضيقي البوسفور والدانيل مرورا
ببحر مرمره وايجاء وصولا الى المتوسط
مساحتها 27 الف كيلو متر مربع غالبيه سكان
القرن من القوميه الروسيه باكثر من 58 في
المئه يليهم الاوكرانيون باربعه وعشرين في
المئه ثم تتار القرم باثني عشر في المئه
روسيا اعلنت في عام 2014 ضم القرم عقب ان
صوتت المنطقه ذات الاغلبيه الناطقه
بالروسيه لصالح الانضمام الى روسيا في
استفتاء تعتبره اوكرانيا والغرب غير
قانوني تشكل شبه جزيره القرم كما كانت منذ
قرون اهميه استراتيجيه بالنسبه لروسيا
بحيث انها تعد بوابتها الوحيده للمياه
الدافئه على البحر الاسود كما تضم مقر
قياده اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي